here he is yeah
[Music]
was that the good luck that was the good
luck squeeze
all right tonight can be the exhale
because we're at the end I already feel
the exam oh it's so good yeah
what does this moment mean when you know
we think of Lisa and I was there in
Memphis and I think of her and what it
would have meant to be here are you
carrying a little bit of her with you
tonight she's carrying a lot of her with
me tonight she said it though early on
she said if he doesn't get nominated for
this movie
that was fulfilled you're here tonight
so I mean you you've been through the
Run of this you were at kind of the
momentum but does it just still sit with
you the character sit with you what
you've done for Elvis's Legacy baz
earlier today was saying you brought him
now to a new generation does that like
compute in your brain
it does because of because of the fans
that I've gotten to talk to so like
these 12 year old kids who told me that
it changed their life and they're
playing the guitar now or
um or it's just brought joy to a little
kid and you just kind of think
that's that's just such a privilege to
get to be a part of something that that
can affect somebody in a positive way
like that what are you doing with all
these Awards and where are you putting
them
I don't know I just didn't you know you
find places shelves and and uh door
stops and things these are Big Awards
and by the way you guys rap Dune right
how was that jumping to Dune and doing
all that stuff so much fun because it
was the uh it was the complete opposite
you know I got to do something
completely different and uh and that's
that's the joy of acting who are you
sharing this moment with tonight
I got my one of my best friends since I
was yeah we need to see his date okay
he'll do he'll do for a date you good
looking thank you how proud are you I
mean I'm gonna be crying the whole way
through no matter what happens what do
you mean
so we met when I was 17. James was was
working at the agency that and then but
as an assistant I was just doing little
TV shows and then we grew up together
you know and he's the guy that I go to
for every career question anything you
know
it's my best friend then I get to work
with yeah so you saw him first show up
as Elvis on the screen were you a puddle
because we didn't normally go and visit
on set and I didn't get to so I got to
see this journey that he went on it was
it was pretty special
oh are you ready for you ready
I've seen you I love seeing you by the
way you know there's this new Zoe movie
coming out any chance that like you
could pop your head in and say hey y'all
and then just walk on out I mean that'd
be funny I I haven't I haven't heard
anything about it really so yeah I mean
I love I love all those people so much
it was a pivotal moment in my life it
was it was uh it was the beginning of a
certain type of chapter yeah
part of like my legacy and who I am and
where I've got to today everything we
ever do just leads us to where we are
now
foreign